hiya I'm Gavin I'm Dan we're the slow mo
guys Dan's very excited today
essentially you wanted to do this one I
just saw a video on the internet of a
guy spinning why war yeah
fireworks sort of thing looks like a
Catherine Wheel except home-made so
except you're the wheel yeah exactly
we've got some wire wheel here very fine
stuff the zero zero zero zero grade and
you sort of puff it out
attach it to some wire spin it round
while it's on fire and because the air
is all rushing through it it's all just
Cajun almost took my art without there I
almost yeah I'm a bit bit worried about
it's cuz we showering sparks in every
direction really hot spots as well so
let's dampen down the grass because uh
you know grass looks good that good idea
for Marshall yeah alright cool is that
sorry Connie because you're not real no
shut up so we usually don't film this
they're late in the day the Sun is
almost completely you know off the
ground but we want the darkness for this
one because we want the fire to be there
the the only light
so what as soon as it goes be it's going
now just go mental with it yeah flick
the neck haha okay hold on hold still
okay go for it
well dan I think that was a majestic
looking video ah so pretty
we experimented with a lot different
stuff like wide open shutter lower frame
rates actually as well just to get the
the light on you and I thought it looked
tremendous it was like a little music
video going on I burned you yeah I won't
put you splashed me with about 500
sparks in the face really enjoying the
neck that is good fun favorite by the
video okay so this is about to go out so
do feel free to follow us on twitter by
shirt and subscribe to the slow mo rise
it's almost like what's that stuff in
minecraft ball that you like that
glowstone glowstone yeah so much that
isn't glowstone cool see you next time
good night do a little whirl
Oh Ferdy what do we expect
Oh dog will say a big thank you to
audible for sponsoring this video to
great service they've got over 180,000
audio books available from things like
sci-fi fantasy to business biography but
a minute I'm listening to the Martian by
Andy weir if you like the movie
you should definitely listen to the book
there's no better way to get involved in
the story and it's really tough it's
much more emotional in the thumbs you
can connect the characters it's book
yeah it's it's out of this world it is
what look just click on a link below
audible.com forward slash slo-mo and get
a free trial you'll love it
you